[Music]
1 4
okay let's go we need to talk about how
to describe vamanos let me know when
pop we're good rolling okay so hannah's
talking
i don't know what to say are we rolling
already yeah oh we jumped
in that corner oh yeah no i don't we
don't you you plan things out and put
effort into your work
and you script it out and you don't know
we just go we don't even shower here as
you can see
not even a 3-2-1 okay rolling nothing so
we're going we're going and we're done
thank you so much for being here all
right my uber's here
see ya that's all we needed that 15
seconds for tick tock bye
um and we got it no
i had such big plans about impressing
you today like
i'm realizing that i don't understand my
generation what
oh not yet emily okay also you're here
the first day that emily is going to
shoot me with a nerf gun if i interrupt
you
no way yeah yeah oh can you shoot me too
look how many nerf darts i have
it's a it's a satchel she's got a set a
bag
i i'm gonna shoot muzzles at your face i
obviously have a tick
where i cannot not interrupt someone
we're working because you get excited i
get excited
i it's not like it's okay it's okay
because i get excited
i get excited just to hear you speak
really yeah
you're such a legend okay anything that
comes out of your mouth i don't know
what to expect
that's the take that's the take internet
yeah there you go
just be excited okay because you're open
arms
i love you that's so nice because i'm
realizing i'm
uh intimidated by you
no no no no okay now i'm gonna interrupt
you okay no
i'm intimidated by you this generation
but i'm also in
awe of you you are just like a staple
for just women and comedy in general and
you've just paved the way to
for so many people and so many careers
and i just look up to you
oh and my family they're all huge uh
fans of you too
making me feel old this is her way of
saying like my grandmother loves you no
and i've had to sit through
your shows and be like can we watch
pewdiepie please like no we're watching
our program whitney's on
whitney is on stop it stop it you're an
actor
no they think it's a they think it's
fran drescher's new show
they're like friends on and it's me
that is so no it's just that's that
thank you that's so nice but i realized
like
you know i was like i want to like look
good and look cute and then
i fully just look like vincent gallo
today you don't even know who that is i
bet
hey uh i don't but i i'm telling you you
look like you know like every art
teacher
i had this whole plan where i was gonna
brush my hair i was gonna put on like a
top and here we go no
this is uh you don't you don't want to
see my hair when it's not
done it is atrocious some is straight
some is curly at least you have
consistency
you've brushed it i'm like i i had to
get it done i can't do it myself have
you ever dyed bleach your hair
um i've bleached like the middle uh
part before it was atrocious it gets so
dry
there's no way to not make it frizzy and
i thought i was having like a victorian
like jane austen moment with my
victorian bun and i just look
like a like a dangerous person so i'm
sorry you had to meet me this way well
now like that only took you two seconds
but now you look like a ballerina
but here's something in the future uh in
la i don't know how long you've been
here but um
if you see a woman that looked like that
don't hug her or say hi
go the other don't go into her house
okay i'm going to put it in my head
i'm very protective of you next time you
see someone that looks like this don't
enter their home
and let her close the door behind you go
the other way just be like no
way not to talk to strangers
uh yeah so i realized i was like nervous
to meet you there's this weird like i'm
so in on you guys because i like cannot
wrap my head around how bad it would
have been
if i had a camera in the internet when i
was your age
oh so many people would be dead yeah i
think
you know that's maybe yeah that's a good
a good point like but for me it's like
i can't imagine going on stage alone and
slanging jokes and making people laugh
like that
i know are you so talented no that's so
nice but it's like it's just so
interesting that there's like a
different
my nightmare would be sitting in front
of like a computer and like editing it
and like not knowing
i guess i'm just gonna send this out and
i guess we'll just see yeah
i know but i mean the beauty comes in
editing it's like with you
it's live and you can't rely on the edit
to take something out of it
nothing i'm saying when it's on nothing
else oh yeah this is
live like i'm just authentic i'm me i
just want
people to know the real me this is an
inside joke of our producers by the way
you guys because sometimes i will edit
out like words i'll be like i started on
that line can you please take it out oh
yeah just hard cut
i'm sounding if you want to do an
intervention you need to cut it i
sound unwell but you're just like i
i love you you come bearing gifts look
at this i love buying people presents
it's kind of pathological and
inappropriate
because we're not that close you're like
a stranger to me so the fact that i
bought you that six months was like
weird
oh and when when we first met in real
life i got you a pray mantis bitch
yeah what is that are we are we do we
think we're not enough and we need to
give each other presents what is it
i think every time we see each other we
can just take turns giving each other
now i feel pressure next time i see him
like fuck
no no next time it's my turn but you
know what's weird about me i don't
um i try not to do too many holiday
gifts i like to do gifts like
when i want to give it's like i want to
give that now i don't want to save that
i'm going to
break it by the time it's christmas but
i won't you won't get a christmas
present from me but you will get a
random present like
in like february in college it's like oh
it's you know you're you're half
birthday yeah i don't but yeah i don't
like that we can only give presents on
birthdays
and uh the other one christmas i like to
do it just whenever but it's weird if i
just give it to you on a random
i'm like i bought that for you six
months it was like weird why i
i like i like the the surprise element
of it like you never really know when
it's coming it doesn't have to be a
holiday or a birthday
i like the whitney present giving way do
your parents
are just nailed it or what why are you
so well adjusted
what do you mean like i i thought the
next generation was like negative
and like man like you're such a like
what kind
like you're such a bright light oh gosh
um
no i think uh yeah i think it's i am oh
golly jeepers
oh gee willis like how did you
not how are you not a monster oh i would
be a
monster you would oh my god like how
like what would you do
okay i am uh i just turned 29.
so what okay and then what are you doing
why do you look like a piece of cake
what's that
uh there's a caked up makeup there you
go i got my makeup done
i want to do this rapeseed oil though
we've talked about grape seed oil
yeah i think that's a secret no i do
that and you do that and we don't look
the same so what else
because no no no i use that too and i
don't look like you so what's going on
no but
i want to do with your face though is it
a cake yeah
with the knife and that just slices it
open i guess you had to learn to do
makeup
really young because like i would never
you did you do your makeup no okay
yeah because that was made me upset yeah
um yeah no i think yeah when i when i do
makeup it takes you know 15 minutes it's
just tinted moisturizer a little bit of
mascara it'll get on my eyelid but
i'll leave it there you know for a
little uniqueness um but yeah no
regarding uh
you know my my upbringing yeah i think i
owe it a lot to my parents and
especially
therapy okay therapy helps a lot
did you go when you started realizing
you were famous were you just like i
should get into therapy
see that's funny you say that i still i
mean i i think i'm
known on the internet i i wouldn't you
know categorize myself as being famous i
i think that um
you know i just got no realization 20
million followers like don't really know
who you are they just kind of followed
you and like who is this oh shit
oh my god did you shoot it
let her finish okay let her finish about
therapy
okay but i'm not here's the one thing i
do interrupt
when i when someone that i have love for
i know it's inappropriate it's it's
premature but i feel like when you're
like women's business you just kind of
bond prematurely if you say something
that i'm an international just don't
um i like it though because if you
interrupt me i have severe
adhd so i immediately am on to the next
topic that's what this whole so i can't
even
remember it was about therapy i forget
my training yeah yeah no we'll get we'll
get you back don't worry yeah yeah yeah
yeah i have covered fog you have adhd
this pod has to be great
this is like this is just a peak
listening experience how was your your
code
it was it was i feel i'm so embarrassed
talking about it uh uh i have like shame
about it talking about it
um because it was so bad
and i i got it so bad and i don't know
people talk about like did i get like a
big viral load or something which
never say ride reload and make eye
contact with me
jesus christ i was at work yesterday and
these people were like it was the viral
load i was like everyone stop saying
viral load jesus weirdly
sexual because you also don't know what
you're saying
you don't know none of us know what that
means who made up that
term i love it that people i've never
heard that before literally like actors
like so is the viral load you don't know
what you're asking and i don't know what
i'm answering why are we pretending
we're doctors none of us know fucking
anything
you know what i mean so what's your
blood type i don't know and you don't
care
but because you have a blood type a you
don't know if that's even true
yeah what is this performance and then
we're all just like performing
a covid conversation yeah and did you
get the pcr test
yeah yeah but the pcr is related to the
rapid
if you were to ask one more question the
whole house of cards would fall down
yeah you know do you know what a pcr
test is and they're like oh no i just
have heard other people say that like
we're all just saying what we've heard
other people say in conversations no but
i guess like nothing is
really set in stones everything is like
changing it's just such a new thing
no there's no point in like like i feel
like as soon as i learn something the
next day it's totally undone so i'm like
i'm not gonna bother learning anything
until
when the doctors tell me what this
fucking thing is i'll learn it then
until then i'm just gonna assume it's
fucking
gonna kill everyone all the time but i
was uh no i was
and i did uh uh i had it so bad but it
was hard i got so much neurological
stuff
and i feel we were talking about it
because i don't like scare anybody but
i don't think that's you can't you know
what i mean like because i got nothing
respiratory was all like neurological
and i was like i didn't know if it was
from the antibiotics because i do very
poorly on antibiotics
um like antiviral i don't know
i'm gonna say it i don't know okay i say
that
i could have just bullshitted and be
like yeah no it was anti-virulent like
what
what does that mean wait wait why did
your generation know about medicine
we never knew anything well i i also i
have a pre-med degree though
what yeah i wait i knew you were like in
biochemistry
um like six years ago yes but now it's
just like strictly videos and internet
so i
i haven't been exercising that part no i
disagree
because i look at your stuff and i'm
like this stuff is so like cerebral not
that you're applying like medical
but it's like i don't think people
understand it requires so much
discipline it requires so much like
dare i say like surgical like watching
your stuff a lot of people
i don't know how you have this it's a it
truly is a gift
the understanding of and we talked about
this all the time emily like knowing
when to cut the time
the comedic timing like when people say
i could never do stand-up the comedic
timing like
it's not that's how i feel but you can't
teach anyone that
you just have to do it it's trial and
error and there's no
way to really tell someone how it's
and how to like make it your own and
differentiate yourself like you can't
like just
copy somebody's style and like succeed
there goes our youtube career i was
about to do a big spelling bee video oh
my god you saw that one
oh that's so funny are you having as
much fun as it looks like you're having
i know i think that's the beauty of of
just starting out
and then just like seeing like what your
creative freedom brings you because
there i mean there wasn't as many eyes
like that that was the most fun time for
me
and you were incubated by fans not
executives
yeah who were guessing what fans want
yeah you're like no i know my
like you were focus group workshopping
with your fan base whereas
a lot of like writers people like i want
to be a writer and even actress i'm like
go make videos and do your thing because
you're not going to be able to
get past all the gatekeepers and do what
you
do exactly what i'm saying yeah because
if you had come to me ten years ago not
me like i would have thought it was
awesome
like but some idiot had been like hey i
want to do a video where my eyes like go
in circles and i because
she has done your research have you um i
googled you this morning did you feel it
did you feel it i felt i feel like you
could feel my google
yeah my eye was going your eyes okay so
what is it why do your eyes do that
um so your eyes go in circles i think
uh i think now is a great time to
finally say it
and i've never said it like publicly but
it's
the effects yeah the effect sorry i
think that would have been something i'm
gay
thanks thanks for the hits thanks for
the hits no please no it's time to come
out we need some youtube
subscribers yeah but you still can do
some of it you can do some of it you can
do
you can totally that okay that's not
fucking vfx wait
am i doing it alone yes that is not very
okay but i can't
you can grasp yeah you can definitely
train yourself you just threw a cover
droplet at me from doing that
yeah gross from your eye just shot out i
don't think that's normal
i don't is it a muscle or is it a vein
try it just cross your eyes in the top
you do it for me i think there's
something with your optic nerve
kind of like being undone that allows it
to float
but i don't think anybody's really been
able to control it like that
however i have heard from some fans
being like
taking a picture of my specific eye
video
on a powerpoint in their class and a
professor is actually
teaching the class like oh yeah look
look at this girl she can actually move
her eye
and dilate her pupils on command and
like
by the way i love your impression of a
teacher yo yo
[Laughter]
where did you go to school that's cool
did you go to the dangerous mind school
it was a crazy like waldorf school
um but let me ask you something because
it's like i do feel like
and then we're gonna watch this yolo
video i cannot wait um
i do feel like there's this like gen z
what is it are you gen z
i am a millennial that's okay i think
i'm kind of cool
yeah you're on the cusp about who gets
that i don't know yeah virgo rising got
it
um are you virgo raising i'm virgo virgo
virgo double burger oh nice we get a
lung
i'm an aquarius oh good no you just to
get along with virgo you just have to do
exactly what they say
yeah and everything will be fine and i'm
a free bird so i'm like okay
as long as you do exactly what i say
every second
perfect and we will beat you um
you keep entertaining me with your eyes
we'll be fine um no uh
what was i saying what was i saying
i don't know do you remember it was
important you okay so
why is this okay so i'm always torn
between this like
you know because i think it's just
because it's like i came up in such a
specific time and then it like kind of
got
like not easier in a way but it got um
more accessible things just got more
accessible out of nowhere
um i think just like being able to start
out make something
yes when i started you couldn't even put
yourself on tape for an audition you had
to find a friend who had a camera
like that's like what's so amazing about
what you've been able to do you've been
able to navigate that
extremely hard space and become the
legend that you are
and i think that like today it is hard
to become you know
a weekly guest slot on our phone yeah i
would love that
no but thank you so much but i
look at you and i do the opposite i go i
would have posted some
i wouldn't have had any of this because
i would have posted something fucking
if half the shit i said in comedy clubs
when i was just making mistakes and
learning i had put on camera and put out
right oh i would be living in a bunker
with matt lauer
in the hamptons like in a whole
somewhere
yeah like the fact that you you have to
be
here's the thing that i love about you
guys you have to be a good person
because i don't think you can get away
with it
as long as we could like
like old hollywood whatever these they
could get away with being assholes for
so long because number one
you don't really see their personality
you guys can't hide that as much as
you yeah you know their team kind of
covers for them yeah
and then there's everything's being you
know and now and in this space too sorry
oh my god
i i deserve it i'm sorry
um no but but i'm just saying there's
something so amazing by going like
i know all of you guys are good people
mm-hmm
and there's something just like kind of
heartening about that yeah because i
know you can't hide anything
yeah we can't and then also like i would
say in my space collabing is such
uh do you know my spaces oh yeah were
you on it i was
yeah i had uh top eight and everything
but i think i was like
on the i had it for like the last like
three months dude i saw tom from my
space on mariah
no i'm sorry wait i think i just peeked
this down
and he and he uses his photo from
myspace which i just was like oh it's so
good
he was my like right like almost
everybody still
my friends my best friends
did you match with him no i don't know
what i did i can't remember i think i
took a nyquil
i don't remember but i also i'm dating
someone what am i saying um
uh but uh but no there's this but you
like
i remember watching you and going like
you i was watching some interviews last
night on
it wasn't like podcasts or something um
and it was very awkward because i think
what happens
with uh is people just expect you to
start going into us doing a sketch and
you're like
oh yeah i know interviews are awkward
right interviews yeah
extreme is this one awkward i'm not i
mean
i think the idea of a podcast is very
awkward with
all these cameras around and people
watching and having a conversation
first date yes but with you you make it
so fun
and easy thank you yeah i'm i'm amazing
i'm just trying
out for my weekly guest spot right now
um but uh no but
what why do you have to be off set like
i was watching you religiously i try to
be authentic and i remember being like
why why i think it's just like why can't
you fucking
do cgi and do like what is the hold on
just
help me understand this so people you
want to see superman
and michael bay movies and cgi and then
but they have that you know i think it's
like the relatability
aspect of you know young girls say they
wake up in the morning and they don't
look perfect
like every other actress does in a movie
you know and they want to see
you know some people do sorry sorry what
i'm getting in trouble
oh you want to shoot me do it
oh my god oh my god holy shit i'm so
sorry that could have taken your eye out
oh my god oh my god
the the ephemeral joy in your eyes
right before it almost killed me and she
whipped it out like
by the way that is that is a woman in
her late 30s in a nutshell
i'm doing my job sorry
let's uh not say late thirties okay
friday okay okay
that's embarrassing in front of me we're
the same age just so now every time i
heard your feelings i hurt my own just
now just know we're in this we're in
this together i'm not just hurting you
i'm also cutting okay
that hurt me more i think than it hurt
you actually okay the problem with this
is that it's interrupting so much that i
now we can't even go back to where we're
just talking yes we can but we don't
have to be a super on like
okay like like there's two things i have
in my head that i want to make sure we
don't
we go back to it could be like a brain
gym exercise like any time we interrupt
each other just boom and then we could
see if we still remember what we were
doing when liza koshy was here
i wasn't even on camera like we went
back through the footage and there was
like nothing intelligent it was just
like
like we didn't we're just talking at
like 300 miles an hour
like no there was no
you i feel like hold on let's eliza
koshy it's just like
um guttural noises the podcast it's just
us being like
crazy um but you guys have such
infectious like positive energy but why
do you so do you
i'm that yes i'm known for my uh
uh positive essence uh but why why do
you have to be
when you're making a video you're like i
have to be relatable i have to be this
but why can't you be aspirational or why
can't anyone can photoshop their eyes
now with a thing
that is inspiring to me to go yeah i
want to be as good as her
yeah i think um which is it do you want
to be perfect or do you want to be
relatable which is it because you want
both because when i'm relatable and
don't wear makeup you say that i'm
busted and when i do my
makeup you say you're creating a false a
bad standard what
is it so you just do that she
interrupted me
get her that back she interrupted my
ramble
that's the that's the battle that i'm
i'm always facing because
if i am trying to be relatable i am
getting negative comments about
my body image or how my face looks or
something like that but you kind of just
have to bite that bullet and just try to
be
inspirational to the young women out
there and hope you can be that role
model and then if you are being perfect
then people are like
is that photoshop
but yeah you just kind of have to like
take again but here's the thing here's
the other thing about that cause i was
talking to someone yesterday
who was like talking about comments
people are allowed
to be insecure and have a shitty day
and anesthetize by judging someone else
or saying
we just used to do it not in the
comments section so for people like
people so negative on the internet
people just negative period they've
always done this there was just never
any proof
yeah there was never any way for us to
access it so i have news for you
15 years ago people were like i don't
fucking like her she's not funny but
we just didn't know about it people like
the fucking internet assistant
oh and now you know about it just so you
know the truth is out this was
always happening people were always
judging you and saying shit that
may or may not be true it may not be
unfair is cruel and mean
but like what is nice about it is if i
put out a video
and it's just all like negative comments
i know it's not going to be a good video
and i just take it down immediately so
thank you haters now by the way you're
just making me better at my job that's
i look at haters yeah as like um well
because this is when tim dillon was on
and he was attacking hollywood
and he was a good fucking hollywood
stupid you have to get notes from stupid
executives know nothing about comedy
on the internet i have to get notes from
people that know nothing about comedy
who are
so much meaner that don't have an hr
department absolutely
yeah i kind of miss these old like like
like creepy guys
like getting free constructive criticism
right there
half full yeah i mean that's what i love
about your mindset you're very
glass-half-full
interesting
i mean we're literal strangers so it's
like it's just you're gonna meet me at
some point and be like oh
and that's why i try to get the podcast
before the person gets to know me jen
i'm saying
why like why did you go into therapy was
it like i just want to get ahead of it
or is it like a specific thing
i think it was it was a built up thing
that i just kind of thought like things
are just superstitious so i'm just
ripping on my hair for no reason
and then i just thought you know i
should go to therapy my mom suggested it
and
i went in and you know it was i've never
really like
been that person to really when was this
i i started like were you famous
yeah i started therapy like three years
ago okay so you had already had a lot of
stuff
yeah had stuff coming at you i bet yeah
totally and then i've always like been
very just like i'm detached i don't
really express my feelings so i would
say like
just people listening if you're
listening to this and you're not really
good at expressing your feelings
to certain people like therapy is
actually like the best thing because you
pay them not to say
anything and you can trust them and it's
at the end of the day it's like a
massage for your brain
it really is like that's such a great
way to put it like it's like
i don't have to like rush through that
like it's like there i mean you do you
have 45 minutes and there's a clock
right there
it's fucking 30 a minute but i mean
i do feel like i'm really curious and
how you know that you're
emotionally what did you just say that
you're reserved or you're
yeah i mean i've always been that way
i've always
yeah it's not that you're not having the
feelings that you're just like don't
want to be private about it yeah
interesting like i just deal with it
alone but if you're like i've never felt
a feeling i've hear about them and i'm
like
i think about that no i i mean when i
was feeling those
feelings alone i wish i was that yeah i
was like how do i
just you felt them but you feel them and
you're just like because i'm so curious
like i'm really good at suppressing the
emotion until and then i give myself
like
okay at eight i'm off and then i can cry
yay
and then i give my my schedule yeah yeah
i schedule nervous breakdowns too is
that what you're trying to say
yes she's like no oh i love that we can
relate on that i just
snotted on myself um so okay so that's
so but this is part of the reason you're
successful too
because this is something that um i was
uh uh
with david de agus the other day a
doctor that comes on the podcast
sometimes and i
a big problem with uh
me having coveted when i had it for
anyone
um i wasn't taking my regular uh
antidepressants
because i was like i just couldn't keep
food down and i was like sick and i was
like
you know um trying to take painkillers
and like i was ordering like weed
tinctures
like just because painkillers like is
that hey we're
so sweet um painkillers don't uh
uh didn't work on it for me on it at all
because i had so much like deep muscle
pain and bone pain you know i had that
too
i couldn't walk i was trying to work out
and i was like working out but i just i
couldn't i couldn't
i wouldn't go away took a nightmare yeah
um and it would wake me up out of my
sleep
yeah nightmare yeah and so i didn't take
my prozac and i wasn't um
in the prozac i basically take four uh
recurring thoughts that are kind of
self-flagellating
and then go on a loop so i like done
work
in 12-step programs in therapy but like
i talked to psychiatrists where i was
like i don't think i'm depressed like i
don't wake up
sad i want to get out of bed i'm if
anything it's the opposite i'm too
motivated i'm too big of a workaholic
like i should slow down more
like whatever i'm addicted to adrenaline
and um
and i was like the only problem is i
will leave a conversation with someone
and just feel like you should have said
that that was stupid oh i'm like that
too
40 minutes it's like 40 minutes i will
say
like i could be like that for the whole
rest of the day and then it will keep me
up all night
yeah no i wonder i i hope i didn't hurt
anybody's feelings i hope that that was
weird yeah
meanwhile they're like i just had a
great time with hannah or they're not
thinking about you at all
yeah they knew or they're thinking the
same thing they're going to say
hannah i should have and then like the
beating myself up thing and it's like
i don't know how to stop it at the end
of the day they're just like oh i wonder
what i should eat for lunch yeah no
like yeah it's not even that serious
you're just like it's like this
it's like the new um uh like it used to
be like like i finally got used to
getting recognized in public
and then i and as soon as i got used to
it um
people would have their phones out you
know and like people are taking pictures
and they're like taking pictures of them
selfies like i was in um
or they're on facetime yeah the phone's
up and then you're like oh god just ask
for a picture
and they're like who are you ma'am are
you the lady from the progressive
commercial
um
that's funny i get kimmy gibler all the
time
whoa you guys see that i don't see no i
don't no
not like i think without without the
glam
if i were to like do that
just go cross-eyes yeah if i would i
could see it if my eyes were going in
circle
uh yeah no i see i get it i get it
i mean but people don't realize how
hurtful they can be when they do that
like just before you compare someone to
someone else not that she's not stunning
now
you know what i'm saying it's just
making me think gibbler is a gay a baby
last time last night was the first uh uh
i guess it was first time i've been
around people and
everyone's like bored and awkward and on
a set and
it's so clear people haven't been
socializing like everyone's like
like the small talk is really awkward
and far away and it's like what like no
one can people are just sweating for no
reason
we can hear each other through the mask
we're going to shake it don't
do it let's not talk let's just not talk
it's not it's like not even worth it
it's like so awkward but there's always
everyone's going you know who you look
like and you're like
you want to take a walk and think about
this because this might fuck up my whole
day i get kevin costner i've had three
people tell me i don't know
like kevin costner and then i did that
face app of like well now you have to
take the math
okay put it back you don't you don't no
you don't you took a second
yeah no no i took a second trying to
think of who kevin
did that face up where you take it and
it'll tell you what percentage
and i got michael costner kevin i got
kevin oh my god i got kevin
i can't see it i got
that's kevin costner fog that's rage
that's that's deep anger
and and female rage
uh that's deep shame
that was not that was that's my thing
about the copenhagen i want to go like
kobe fox and it's like no i think you're
just being a fucking bitch
and i like like my dude my dude my lover
any time
he's mad at me i'm like i think he's
covered fuck he's like no you you
texting your ex at midnight it's not
covet fog
right
how much longer can i ride out this
excuse me i need to be on the bottom
covered fog i just can't be able to i
don't know how much longer i can use
that excuse
me we now take a break in our hannah
stocking joy extravaganza
to talk about how emily needs stitch fix
i do i hate all my clothes i don't like
to dress myself
if someone could dress me i want to be a
baby here's
here's here's because this is a
basically a personal stylist
that you take a bunch of quizzes and
they just send you clothes
that are cool and fashionable and you
don't have to make any decisions
and you don't need a subscription see
that's why emily's here
she focuses on the details the
nitty-gritty
that i would never have read in this ad
that's an important thing
so you're not obligated yeah you can try
it once or you can sign up for automatic
delivery see that
as someone with commitment issues i
really appreciate that i don't want to
be
everything for me has to be month to
month subscriptions
relationships police leases employees
antidepressants this is like every month
i need to revisit so one thing you
shouldn't do month to month every month
i'm like i don't
let's try a new one let's and that could
be why
why we're here that's why we're here
isn't it
god damn it get started today at
stitchfix.com
whitney and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.comwhitney for 25
off when you keep everything no offense
but if you're listening you need this
stitchfix.com whitney come be a baby
with me
babies don't i guess they do have
wardrobes yeah they get dressed someone
picks their clothes and gets them
dressed so it's true
stitchmate you want to wear onesies all
day
hey emily yes whitney is there something
interfering with your happiness
or is preventing you from achieving your
goals now don't say me
how long do please donate we're trying
to keep these less than a minute
right yes i have a list of grievances i
have a
litany of problems that could probably
be solved by just quitting this show
one of my biggest problems is that
therapy's too expensive it's not only
too expensive
always just too far it's time expensive
it's emotionally expensive
45 minutes i expressed to my therapist
anxiety about having to spend 240
an hour for 40 minutes people are like
what's bothering you the price of this
and you know what's the distance of this
from my home and she didn't have any
helpful feedback on that because just
like smile and nod can we just really
quick talk about the fact that emily
went to a therapist once on halloween
this is my favorite this we shouldn't
bury this in an ad i hope you this will
teach you guys to not skip ads
because our ads are better than the
podcast at this point
um emily went to a therapist on
halloween and he showed up in a
fox costume and didn't dress up he was a
cat oh she was a cat with a
black nose whiskers ears
and a tail and a tail a bushy tail
and first session first session and he
was a psychiatrist this was a
medicine doctor and it was a random
wednesday it was like a rant it wasn't
you know what i mean like
and it was at a doctor's office like i
he walked in and i almost fell over
right dude and the fact that you sneaked
oh and then i sneaked two pictures
oh we'll put them up i sneaked two
pictures and he sat down and looked at
me
seriously and tried to talk to me about
like
my mental health as a cat as a cat
meow i was like what
so i left with a prescription i didn't
need
for my cat allergies for my allergies
yeah i don't even remember his name but
i was just like
it was comical by the way if you knew
his name don't say it no the pokemon
yeah if you remember it please don't say
it i don't trust any adult that comes to
any psychiatrist on my bad side but i
don't need any adult
i'm sorry if you do this like adults
that come to work dressed for halloween
i already have a problem with
you're gonna try to help me so emily
maybe we could work on your anger issues
with betterhelp.com you need
betterhelp.com
i definitely do better emily needs
betterhelp.com online therapy to
complain about her in-person therapists
yes 100.
100 um so as you
look doing therapy in person i just feel
like that was
ridiculous we had a good run so 2019.
not necessary anymore
betterhelp.com is solving this problem
that better help is like when
restaurants learned about
like fast food model and you're like oh
this is so much faster yeah
betterhelp.com is more affordable than
traditional offline counseling
and financial aid is available this
podcast is sponsored by better help
and good for you listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
slash whitney if you're so if your idea
terrorizes you while you're working
you can sue her and then go to
battlesome.com but then go to
betterhelp.com
thank you betterhelp.com for better help
are you going to do live shows when
we're back like comments
you've done some yeah i will appreciate
that as a fan i think that's just like
such a muscle and such an amazing thing
you have to do more you have to tour
something yeah
i don't know i i do that
i don't know yet you can use why not
i'll have you put like a stage show
together no yeah
i'll take 90 percent of the profits uh
but i'll help you and i'll help you just
friend a friend i'll tell you where we
just want to support other women if me
you and tim dillon just went on like
your demo and his demo in the same
building no thank you
kids and then dylan that would be that
would be fun
literally like yeah no i don't yeah like
i don't his fan base would have to uh
ask for a respite
from prison i think you have to like to
get out to come and go back there's no
way but yeah you have to tour no way
gosh but you can do you can do an
interactive thing like i think people
think tori and the way touring's going
to come back doesn't look very different
than the way it was before
so doing stuff on a screen and playing
videos and doing you know oh yeah
absolutely yeah i just have my own
little twist on it and i do
have an excessive amount of energy i
still consider this the morning just
because i woke up so early so i'm not
peak energy so what i do need to release
is this just joy what is it is this just
a good childhood
i don't know what is it oh my my energy
oh the therapist
i don't know you're just having like so
i think i used to be like this actually
no no i think i used to have energy i
look at her
by the way you're looking at yourself in
10 years so just just but you
you have the energy though not really
you're lifting me up a little bit what i
realize is like
this i normally am like kind of almost
bordering on manic
but
i am it's terrific it's true like i have
kind of a manic energy
and i think that a year into the
pandemic i realized i started to get
depressed i just started to get like
okay this is getting
i i think i channel yeah i channel that
into just i know that there's just so
much energy and it needs to be released
i need to scream once you gotta let it
out
where do you what do you do something i
mean
anywhere let me ask you with your the
people that you have on like i'll see
someone go like viral on
whatever what does that even mean how
many is there a definition for that um
i think viral is like what does that
mean i think if like if other meme pages
pick up on it and start reposting it
and yeah it's like it spreads everywhere
like a viral load
of viral i was always curious because
people will say they'll be like that
video went viral i'm just like so
curious is there a number
that or is it subjective i think i think
the number is subjective but i also
think
that it's it's how much it spreads i
think we should pick a rule
also i think it is subjective because i
think if a video does over 40 million
that's viral
oh jesus christ so how do you do you
know that that is like
40 million views i mean that's
three friendses in terms of numbers yeah
like i don't think you guys understand
how much more
successful you are than you're the
people you look up to
i'm just i'm just telling you from a
number no it's like i'm just telling you
i i'm worried about you like i don't
like you guys are famous in a way that's
like so
wild and yeah yeah do you know what i'm
saying
it's wild in this sense like i i feel
like with
you it's it's you see your fans you
interact with your fans for me it's all
behind a screen
yeah so i don't actually see and
interact with them as much unless i
leave my house
and then i'm like oh yeah sometimes
there are times where i'm looking around
like who are they
what are they running towards or
something because i forget i'm just i
don't see it
first yeah yeah yeah yeah that's so
interesting but you guys i mean it's
like there's a
you know the biggest tv show like say
comedy is probably like six million
probably what do you mean uh
viewers yeah oh yeah yeah i mean it's
like these
it's just like it's a different kind of
fame that there's no blueprint for and
just
this is not gonna end well for you i'm
just saying
there's no bloopers yeah you can
definitely yeah it's different than
it's not like disney channel it's not
like being a child star it's not like
being famous yet
it's a different kind of fame that no it
is a gamble it's like some days
you crush and you just produce
heaters or you produce deleters okay
you just gotta delete them yeah because
it just doesn't perform well
but are there ever times where you're
just what's wrong with that what do you
mean
like it doesn't perform yeah what's
wrong with just being like man that
one's for me i think uh
are you like your business so you have
to go like this has to hit
and also with what i do it's just
immediate instant gratification
uh because you just see all the numbers
flood in and then when you post
something that doesn't
get the right numbers it's like gosh
it's like i almost fallen a lot of
people do i've talked to other
internet people and they also fall into
the little ethers almost and they're
just like hey
gosh you know like i'm not getting the
rush of serotonin or
anything or dopamine what's what's going
on yeah and so it's just like
it's addictive so rat race yeah so for
you it's like it's it's interesting so
is it yeah as content creators you guys
it's a little more like
the gauge is is is your instinct where
it's like
in tv and movies you don't get to pick
if something comes out or doesn't or
where it comes out
right and if you pull it down like you
don't get to say like i didn't like that
let's can we pull it down you're like
right like i'm in that embarrassing
movie you know yeah so it's like it's a
lot of like your judgment oh
yeah pretty much and then managers and
i'm yeah that same
rush feeling i feel like it probably
correlates for you if you get like a
big explosive laugh huh um yeah i've
gone a little numb
what happens is is it it's the the the
what is it the thing
what's it the goal post move is that the
expression i keep saying
the covet fog is also making me say like
dumb shit like yesterday i was like
you can lead a horse of water but you
can't teach it to fish
like what i don't think something my
grandpa would say i'm like mixing up
platitudes like i don't know what that
like i'm just like it's just making me
dumber
it just makes me dumber yeah and you
know how it annoys me because it's
ah it's this is the fucking this virus
is so fuck it's the perfect
uh covet fog perfectly feels like
someone's drunk like kind of you know
like i'll just
i'll just be like anyway still um what
yeah what were you talking about i know
it seems like i'm alex lerner
because uh the these he said these
muscles kind of stopped working up here
oh no way yeah
yeah not botox i just had like a little
like neurological stuff in my
head oh just you specifically
specifically yeah
a lot there's some other people that had
like bells paws but that could have been
from stress or something else because i
was like
yeah i had a lot of crazy shit i that
reminds me
and i do i want to circle back and hear
about your hallucination where you
broke your nose
it's how you just breathe into it it's
just so embarrassing because
i know that everyone's building a case
that i like need an intervention there's
something very wrong with me
unless yeah if you don't want to talk
about it we don't yeah it's literally i
mean emily can tell emily knows more
about me than anyone
it's truly just i'm this
nuts i'm ju i like i know i wish i could
say like you guys
i had a bad run with whiskey and that's
over
and i'm back on the wagon my thing is
like i don't know what i wish i could
say like well that addiction's over i'm
like nope that's still just my
personality
oh god uh but uh wait so you weren't
like
i don't want anything i was so paranoid
i got really paranoid
because it was a kind of pain where you
go
like i felt like i was like fighting for
my life it wasn't like i'm just gonna
i'm definitely gonna survive this and
i'm just gonna like
watch your shit's creek and like get in
bed and like have
a couple sick days this was during covet
right when you had covered this is when
i covered yeah
but normally it's just like i have the
flu i'm being sick or i can work through
it or whatever
this was a type of sick where i was like
i was like making plans i was like
calling i was like
like i need to put a will together i was
like making plans for
who was gonna inherit my house like
that's how like
fight or flight it got for me no way
because it was a type of like pain that
was like
it was like um uh a ghost was like
beating me up
no way i mean like i was just like oh
like it was like did you see the
invisible man
i did i did yeah you're just like you're
just getting like knocked across the
room
that was yes it was like it was like
that because just there you
i i don't know how you but i it wasn't
like okay my
stomach hurts and it's gonna it was like
this rib hurts and then it was like this
knee like i
it felt like you're just getting shot no
way is that where you had emily i had
like
i said this like uh i felt like you know
how you clip in and out of a bike or
like
as someone puts a cigarette out you like
twist your foot
i feel like someone was doing that all
over my body putting cigarettes out on
like not the burning but just the
physical you didn't like that
that's not a thing a little nice little
way like that
sounds amazing but just like they were
twinges they were like sporadic twinges
okay so i want to talk about this
because you wait first
sorry to cut you off how did she get
shot because you don't do it to guess
how how did you hit your nose oh shit
sorry okay because yes this is
okay so and here's what i'll say i just
want everyone to know i do not lie if i
lie
it's an accident okay i just forgot and
just got confused
but so i it's gonna sound like a lot of
the things that happen to me sound like
lies
because but why wouldn't this is just
your life the problem is so fascinating
it's like the thing when
people like always thought i lied about
my age my thing was like i didn't
the reason the only way i can get you to
believe me is to just know that
why would i make up that age i would
never get away with it so
know if i was gonna lie i'd give myself
a little wiggle room like
um so i am in bed
like in pain what time is it pain yeah
pain four in the morning okay i love
that in the morning
and i couldn't sleep i was i'm gonna i
snorted a lunesta
told me to do this it's a sleeping pill
you don't have trouble sleeping
so you crush it yourself no i crushed it
finally the doctor was like because i
couldn't keep it down i couldn't keep a
painkiller down there's like a hundred
dollar bill
i can't
do you think i would know how to get
cash myself wait so so you crush it up
yourself and just i know so i crushed it
up with a spoon and it was like snorting
lunesta
i snorted a percocet i was is this crazy
we are not we are i'm so glad we started
in this business we are not endorsing
this behavior
look this is this is crazy
i am a self-help authority i'm an
authority on
all things health me and joe rogan are
real
doctors listen to us yes so i swear
and i so it was like i snorted a little
percocet i also
ordered this weed i was in so much pain
all that's right i'm surprised more
people aren't dying from overdosing on
on drugs trying to stop the pain jesus
yeah
i was i was taking like four advils a
day
too but not nothing compared to what you
did
so you like candy okay great like what
like ad what's an anvil i take four
advil every morning when i'm feeling
you're talking about she's like every
morning just to get out of bed
i take four hours a day just for this i
take it because i'm 30 years you're like
i
drink like i drink the liquid gels
to hydrate myself um
and so okay so i'm staying at a
different house because my house is
being renovated
and i i do not understand the
the way people design their homes every
home i go into i'm like this house makes
absolutely no sense
yeah i feel that way too anything made
sense which is obviously my fault
everyone's got their own thing i'm sure
people come to my house and like this
literally
there's by the bed there's the coffee
table by the
master is about the size of this table
right it's like it's like a
coffee table yeah that's crazy side side
tables are side they're supposed to be
small with a little drawer
put your little dining room table yeah
put your whatever your suicide note in
there
your lube whatever you keep in the side
of your thing whatever polar opposites
of what you just said to the lube
i don't know tissues and whatever you
keep by there you know
your your alex baldwin autobiography
whatever you have by your bed
without whatever you want the normal
stuff that everybody has by their back
right um and so uh uh
i was so cold i don't know when you had
cover you just i was freezing
yeah i was too terrible chills yeah the
chills
like i was just like so cold and i woke
up and i was like so cold
i started getting angry too like like i
had severe frustration too until i
started crying i was like
what are my body aches gonna go away
and i just started shooting tears out of
my eyes it was just so sad
you're like an actual meme just yeah
yeah yeah but that's what it is those
cartoons
yeah but it it's a thing where it's like
because there's no if someone's
irritating if someone just said you're
gonna be sick for ten days it's gonna
suck
and i'm like great and everyone was
having the same thing because then you
get this like well she only had for two
days am i making this up am i being
historic
is this like i started it became like
being in a haunted house with my own
mind
like it got into like maybe i'm not this
sick maybe i'm making up maybe i am
being dramatic
i don't know because then it's like you
think it's your fault if it's worse
yeah because what did you do to make it
worse on what's your blood type
oh it's okay is that even set in stone
is that an actual thing
yeah yeah like i failed somehow because
my cove is really bad and it's just
like it's just like embarrassing and
people feel too sorry for you so you
don't even want to tell them
and then also when you tell someone you
had it they don't they it doesn't make
them feel better
yeah it's like about being writing is
even a real thing yeah because
but they're like i got you know
everyone's like you got the antibiotics
and then when you have them no one's
like
through anybody someone's like oh you
had covenant i know it doesn't help it
really doesn't say i had coveted i'm
safe does not make people feel more safe
absolutely not so how did you hit the
wall oh god
um so oh my god she's like had it with
me
no i'm just so curious this story keeps
getting like crazier and crazier it's
amazing
the people want to know i should not
have a podcast i cannot keep stam on top
for more than five minutes like why am i
doing this i'm so bad at this job it's
wild
oh this is why you have a podcast that's
amazing that's right you just like go on
conversations yes
um and so uh but i know what it's like
to be on a podcast and the host being
like go back to the thing i want to
enjoy this too
like i want to hear the end of the story
do i get to have any say in how this
goes
um okay so middle of the night i got a
space heater
a fucking amazon i was so cold the night
before
to put the space heater in uh uh
uh it was like under the table and it
wasn't i kept turning it on it wasn't
plugged in and i was like oh
and i bent over to plug it in the only
reason we know this is because there's
blood on the table
we found that later i thought i walked
into a beam and so uh
we found it later i slam my nose trying
to
i slammed it was literally just like i
just was like it's
what must have happened because there's
just like a blood on the you know
thing and uh uh i went back to bed
that's how fucking high i was and then
uh my lover said at six in the morning i
crawled into his room
like so dramatic like crawling oh yeah
because i i felt dried blood on my face
because i always put oil on my face like
the first time
when i wake up is grape seed oil on my
face and i was like i felt crustiness
and this is how sick i am at first i was
like why is my skin so dry
and then i looked in the mirror and was
like oh thank god it's just oh my gosh
you're like well at least i'm
moisturizing oh my god it's just dried
blood okay
oh god i was worried that i was
dehydrated every second i saw a
christmas food start to form
my gosh so what made you think that you
ran into a bean
because in this house there's a beam
you're
tall which i have questions about how
tall how young were you when you got
this tall
oh i was pretty young it's a it's a kind
of trauma yeah
it yeah and then i i was very skinny i
think i was five
ten pounds really traumatic oh wow 90
pounds in middle school
in like seventh grade wow yeah is that
why you like like to work out and get so
strong
um i think uh i think that's i mean i've
always grown up very athletic i have
always had this kind of energy that i
need release so i've always been in
sports and um
like i think you should be the wonder
woman oh my god don't you think sweet of
you
but i was also i also played volleyball
in college too so oh so
that's what that is i do now work out
once a month not a lot
uh what what yeah yeah yeah
do you bank it and then post it in your
store okay maybe that's yeah yeah okay
maybe that's recycled recycle the
content i think that's what i think is
important now
like i will when people say like this is
an unrealistic expectation of my life
too
yeah well like do you know what i'm
saying like this isn't like this is what
bums it's like
are we supposed to be balancing out the
unrealistic with the realistic
this is what i'm about time how are
people able to wake up so early
i'm presenting the best version of this
oh the version i want you i'm curating a
version
yeah that isn't embarrassing like why is
that
why aren't people like you need to
embarrass yourself on children media and
you need to reveal all your secrets and
you need to tell everyone you're
molested and post photos of you that
make up like
no i signed up for a business where you
go
you they make you look the best you've
ever looked that's what people see
and then people don't see the other
stuff exactly exactly
i mean it's hard it's hard waking up in
the morning working out
having sweat in your hair you have to
shower you have to wait for your hair to
dry
and then put on hair and makeup and try
to figure out this this mess
yeah but it's like yeah it's like i
don't know it's just like it's
just creating an unrealistic standard
well like if i didn't look like this you
wouldn't follow me so what would i do
you like them you like me doing the
makeup so what is it what is it i know
yikes yeah what do you want you have to
balance so much pressure i feel like you
do you feel pressure to be a role model
um yeah i do um
i think you i definitely want you to
know to do everything
like there's so many platforms there's
so many videos
there's so much more i could be doing at
all times i'm sure
maybe you feel that way too but i think
it's just you know the business that
we're in
so you do have this because it does like
i think that like
i realized that um i almost preferred
the fucked up dysfunctional system of
uh hollywood television because at least
like
you couldn't work unless you were at
work
right whereas now i can't imagine like
like being 29 and being able to like
make something at any point and upload
it because as for me as like
in my like workaholism and my like
desire
to overcome and make it
like the only thing that stopped me from
like having a full
like heart attack or a major health
crisis or like just not taking care of
myself
like destroying myself and probably like
an adderall addiction in my 20s
was me going like well i have to go to
bed now because i can't shoot anything
because i don't
right the camera people are at a
building tomorrow that i have to go to
exactly you have to wait until they're
there
it's it's all consistency and motivation
that's that's what it comes down to
so what do you do did you just teach
yourself to edit
uh yeah yeah i'm i'm self-taught 100 uh
because i went to school for
for pre-med and then i kind of just fell
into it what kind of bed did you think
you wanted to do
um i i was gonna go into surgery
i wanted to be a surgeon that's what
editing is pretty much
i know yeah you're right you're honest
freaking smart
thank you no but it is it is dissecting
rearranging editing used to i don't know
what kind of surgery you're doing
you don't move things from the front
where you're going to pee at plastic
surgeons just like this here
yeah see what this intestine looks like
this looks better than that the game of
opera aesthetically
i like this better oh i know you like
your lungs there but it does look so
much better
just like hear me out shoot me out so
emily have you
um seen any balls recently you know what
i
have not seen balls since i got broken
up with um
i'm really looking forward to the next
now you're just bragging i've seen
a lot of balls since she went through
your breakup i told you that that crazy
man in my apartment
tried to see me with the crossbow came
out butt naked
that's the first pair of balls i saw
tried to shoot you with a crosstalk me
and four police officers
in a in an elevator so the takeaway from
this story is if that man had just
used manscape on his balls you would
have been you would not have had a
problem with this behavior
right it would have been a more pleasant
first
ball sighting post my relationship it
would have been a more pleasant attack
on me more aesthetically you guys are
going to attack women in a hallway with
a sword what was it
a a crossbow you gotta shave your balls
first or i also think you're crazy
do you know what i'm saying you gotta
use the ball wipes these are deodorizing
ball wipes
that you know what i did not put i'm
gonna use on my
armpits right now and we'll see how they
how it goes oh great
they're deodorizing moisturizing and
anti-chafing for on
the go ball camera oh how does it feel
it's pretty soft here's what i'm saying
normally when you use a man's
products they're not good right they're
like they're rough they're
they're coarse no one put any thought
into it but manscape they're making like
quality products for men they realize
men
there's been a reckoning and women no
longer want
rug burn on our chins we have to go to
work now
so you have to pull your balls together
emily you're smelling that
this is just my armpits though it's the
bigger problem
but it smells like a boyfriend
so uh wait were we doing the
betterhelp.com ad
no this is for mansion okay got it okay
so yes go please yeah they have tons of
amazing men hygiene products on their
website everything from disposable mats
for your pubes
to deodorant i'm sorry am i getting in
trouble for saying this is not just for
guys
this thing the look at this it's a what
do you call this it's a
like a portable get top kit it's a tiny
stuff you need for your nails
in one place which i first had a problem
with because i've seen enough men cut
their nails
on a plane while we're flying no fly
list
don't please don't do that um but
this is yeah men having portable nail
clippers
this is gonna win win for everyone
backfiring uh on a plane
but what yeah just because guys think
they should just right right right right
cut their toenails like right
near sinks right the guy i'm dating put
his foot up on
i was like can you do that in a sink
like just or a toilet
i walk in his foots up on the kitchen
sink i'm like
dude not that i ever go near that sink
but i'm sure that's gross for someone
that will 100
crop reviver is spray on toner for your
balls yes please
toner is great these and balls all look
like they're 100 years old for some
reason they need this
they age they look like like dried
apricots elephant ears
not anymore cleanser hair and body wash
yes please
so 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code whitney that's
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code whitney
thanks manscape for making our winter
wieners look so good
honestly i'll apply it if you guys will
start using it i will
put it on your to them now
that's how we need to start selling this
i'll set up a different email for that
i will is if you i'll apply it if you
use it how about that
uh and then i'm gonna need a new job
so okay um bandscaped
thank you i am truly obsessed
with the um lollipop drinks
okay when you guys look at our podcast
table
and see the 900 just cans of trash
but it just looks like a yard sale in
here it's
because i got obsessed with olipop it is
a
supports digi it's a so it's like a
healthy soda the only thing i've ever
wanted in life
a soda that doesn't make you feel like
shit and make you feel bad about
yourself
it's an alternative to soda it tastes
like a coke or whatever or like they've
got all these like
vintage flavors where's the strawberry
did i drink it
there's a cream strawberry flavor that i
i think i drank it already
um but it's got only
three grams of sugar non-gmo vegan paleo
keto friendly
less than eight grams net carbs per can
now what what wowza like wowza
like you i mean i know you like to like
get into your shame spirals with your
regular sodas
that have proven to give people numerous
uh health problems
so which one do you want to try do you
want to try the vintage clothing i want
to try vintage i'm going to have emily
try
one i'm very excited the ginger lemon
this is the sparkling tonic that is
sometimes i'll put a little
little drank in here do i mean all right
emily's trying her first
olive pop it's a hundred percent money
back guarantee
for orders place that's good that's good
right hold on i'm going to try that
i have the root beer one it tastes like
i'm at the soda shop
it does it tastes like you're down at
the getting a phosphate
i love it yeah the alternative but i'm
saying like i feel like as an adult i
can't just be pounding soda anymore yeah
i used to drink so much
soda but this is i still drew but this
would be a much better option i mean
look how much
look at this oh it's so much less
calorie by the way but the root beer
this truly tastes exactly like root beer
i can't
well can we try i mean you don't like
grouper no i do like root beer but she's
weird
but germs wise i'm not sure i'm not
offering it to you oh i was gonna ask
about it no
i'm not you can't share sodas in a
pandemic i'm pretty sure
okay all right i'm sorry about that god
we both had covenants now
we're a podcast but okay
but i like it so here's the thing
everyone's home
like i don't know i just feel like you
have to make what used to be very
mundane tasks
special because we have so few special
things we can do right now
you deserve a little treat treat
yourself yeah you know get yourself a
fancy
soda that makes you feel special and
like you're
um a woman that wasn't allowed to work
in the 50s oh look
so much easier back then that's what i'm
aiming for now no pressure
of your career goals lollipop is so
confident that you will love their
products that they offer a 100
money back guarantee for orders placed
through their website we've worked out
an exclusive deal for the good for you
podcast listeners receive
20 off plus free shipping on their
best-selling variety pack
this is a great way to try all of their
delicious flavors go to drink
lollipop.com
whitney or use whitney at checkout to
claim this deal
that's d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
dot com slash whitney this discount is
valid only for their variety pack
this is just so they put me on the
screen too while you're talking okay
well we don't i know how to not let you
take over and steal
my thunder i know that's we're working
on if you guys are watching
uh i'm doing things to
just take my moment yeah take her
lollipop can also be found in over 3 000
stores across the country including
whole foods sprouts kroger
wegman and heiron i get why people
heckle it's so tempting
yeah it is and it's also hurtful
i'm just sitting here like yeah like i
like never go to a comedy show i don't
know how people when i get mad at people
they heckle i know i'm not mad anymore
i'm sorry yeah people didn't let you
talk for an hour yeah it's
awful well like one night when it's so
boring when i go to one of your
next shows i'm just going to sit in the
audience and mouth what you're saying
is that me laughing like a joke that's
you right now
is there ever a time where you're like
i'm maturing or like i
my taste is changing and i wanna like is
my
do i have to stay absolutely i think
evolving is such an important part of
you know just
in the comedy business for you probably
and also
in the internet they don't let us we
just get old and they forget about us
we've never done that before i can't
wait to see what you what what this
looks like
no i i feel like yeah there is something
called fan fatigue so if they see the
same thing over and over it's not going
to perform as well so
you always have to be evolving yeah but
i think in my case
um i was raised you know to be
competitive in sports and then double
major and
that's all i knew i didn't really have a
social life i
i went to college but i didn't have a
social life
and i was up at f 5 a.m to do
6 a.m practice and then i was in las
vegas all day yeah for
volleyball in labs all day i had my game
then at 11 30 p.m i'm
culturing my stem cells in the lab like
i just had no life at all so
i think because i was on the internet
and i know put on my face
i think just the life that i was raised
into
i don't know what else to do except to
work
hard but this is what i was just having
this conversation
with ben and two about about another
thing which is like
but there's nothing you've done
that per like prepares you that anyone
for being in charge of people
how are you but sports i think people a
lot of times don't understand like
like when they're like i'm going to be a
creator i'm going to be a boss and i'll
be this like okay well do you know how
to deal with someone who's mad at you
but not
be bitchy and not be passive aggressive
and not be like okay well
i think you want me to do this tomorrow
and like you can't do that yeah there's
a level of
like you can edit you can write you can
be a comedian you can do this and i can
but just engaging different people's
personalities
you're the leader it's like it's like no
one prepares you for that
do you know what i mean i mean i guess
you must have gotten it from playing
sports because you have to communicate
and you have to like play
having your coaches yell at you and then
like trying to pick up your teammates
absolutely and you have to know how to
talk to people for
10 hours a day in this same tight space
but this goes back you just have to be a
good person
it is yeah it's survival of the nicest
now you have to now it used to be you
had to be talented at first it was nice
guys finished last now i think
yeah you just have to be nice you have
to be a genuine person yeah and if
you're not like it's just like
your stuff's not going to be good either
because i think right now people don't
want negative
toxic shit they can't yeah you know but
but
i just i think that that's promising i
think like the internet like in a lot of
ways people this is like the worst and
it's bringing out all the trolls and i
think it's actually like you know
shedding light and and adding jokes and
that's what you're so amazing at too
it's almost like we're providing
almost like free laughs to everybody and
hopefully
the ticket prices are going up they're
going up just preparing
but still but still i i think that um in
this time
in a time of such negativity i think it
is so important to
produce laughs to to our fans and
hopefully make this world a better place
i mean yeah i mean and so what
um would you say i'm before we get into
this other thing
um uh our surprise uh event for the show
which is me getting tetanus
uh from here oh yeah uh tana's a
what would you call it extreme tattoos
what do you use okay so
at the start of quarantine um i went
through a rampage of different
quarantine purchases
i bought a stripper pole uh-huh um
a lot of other random things lightsaber
chopsticks
cute um i mean where's the lightsaber
i mean oh you're onto something
yes and then also a tattoo gun then i
just started tattooing
myself and then i tried tattooing my dad
he didn't he wasn't for it and now
a lot of my friends are just yo like i
have
i have like 50 friends being like on the
wait list just to get a tattoo from me
okay so you this is like a you just
started doing there's not a there's not
like a thing you've been doing a while i
think i've tattooed like 50 people
though
okay okay okay we're i'm gonna get a
uh a tattoo today from hannah are you
actually
i don't know okay let's let's see
uh uh yes if i don't start hemorrhaging
i don't know i might be
who knows with my covered blood things
might go sideways do i need to have had
a tetanus shot i feel like i've had one
no i had one in 2018.
okay yeah i'm also using a sterilized
needle
yeah okay so yeah yeah should be yes
yeah no i
should clean off the surface there look
honestly after what just happened with
kovid i am
if i didn't just die in the last couple
months i'm invincible
life is a simulation wait so this is
just a tattoo gun you've got
what do i do oh i'm definitely going to
want i want to do uh
emily's name on my foot
and then where do you what's the
where what what's your specialty my
specialty is like a smiley face on the
bottom of the foot
oh that's like a no-brainer sure yeah
yeah and it's quick too
even i would do that okay yeah it's
gonna tickle though okay let's do it
let's do it let's do it obviously i
wanted to do like a thing back here
okay i'm saying i tattooed somebody's
neck yesterday actually wait no out of
this sleeve
huh with you hopefully it was shading
she's like i don't want to
but disclosure i'm not a professional
and my friends are idiots
let's go
not a professional i have health
insurance my friends are idiots
i want to die young i got this on amazon
literally for our listeners hannah is
taking her tattoo
kit out of a box a clothing box oh yeah
it's
just there's a pineapple sticker on it
like do you this is like i do have i
think a sweatshirt came in
it's about your
you have nine people working for you and
this is the box no it's fine it's good
it's just like you know
staff of nine people and this looks like
a yard sale
like this yard what is that
blood like what is on this box champion
box like i don't even know
um i want to i want you to talk through
setting this up
and i'm going to pee okay cause i just
got scared
but i'm just shitting just pooping i've
soiled myself
i've soiled myself like as if there's no
backing out now
okay so i am okay plugging this guy in
let me move my this paper
so do you want tattoo paper um where i
um
i draw it out and then i just it's like
a tracing paper
that i pre-brawl it free ball it are you
are you what do you mean
racing out whatever emily's a pussy she
you trace hers out you know you trace
mine
okay oh wow this is exciting
i have tattoos my tattoos are white
mostly what so i have one right here
you can do with white ink yeah that's a
little anchor i've white
because i was like very non-committal
this is like
and i told the guy that i'm dating about
this and i was like no i'm not afraid of
commitment
my tattoos are just white um i want them
to be there i just don't want to i just
don't want to like have to see them all
the time it's like well that's a point
of tattoo
that's why i got this my my inner lip
before i got any tattoo
not the not the response i was expecting
yeah wait so this is
it was like an infinity sign hold on no
just because of commitment
issues yeah but what you thought putting
it on your lip was less of a commitment
than
where that's on my body so nobody can
see it
i don't okay okay it's faded it didn't
hurt i i just had a chips and salsa
right afterwards
my first tattoo would not be
i know here's the inside of my mouth i
know
you're like i'm not i'm i like i'm kind
of not in a tattoo so i put one
in my face like that that's such a cute
little hiding place so invasive i know i
would not have thought i'm gonna hide
this in plain sight honestly i know the
only
like guys that really see it as my
dentist but isn't that great
i was gonna say it's annoying it's
annoying when you have to i find that
i have to lie about my tattoos because i
just don't want to tell the same story
over and over again
so people like do you have any tattoos
i'm like no it's like i just don't
but you and i don't have to show them
because as soon as someone
wants to see your tattoo you then have
to be like okay take your shirt it's
like why do i owe you the all this
information about how many do you have
can i see
all of them oh yeah no and then it's
just sort of like why am i
and then you have to be like airs on my
lip you have to like touch and then take
off my shoes
yeah i do that willingly like my thing
is just like you don't get to see my
tattoos like
like you know it's like somebody's like
can you see your tits and it's like
sure but there's something about it like
when someone wants your tattoos you're
like
fair enough but i'm so excited because
i'm about to tattoo you right now is
this actually happening
how long does it like first of all don't
have to shave the area that you tattoo
but are we doing the bottom of your foot
unless you're frodo i think you're good
yeah your feet look fine
my feet look fine but there is like do
you ever
like get a one random black hair like on
your ankle
no you never was like
[Music]
than i've ever seen at a tattoo store
that's longer than most of them hannah
no
no it's not a needle that's a dagger
that is an actual dagger that is a ninja
star she's pulling out a ninja star
um a rusty ninja star
[Music]
i mean this is just do the antibodies
protect
from tetanus yeah i read that somewhere
i'm in a covent fog i want you to know
that hannah's taking advantage of my
coping fog
yes she's like i'm so excited can we get
in there before whitney's brain clears
up
and she starts making good decisions
again by the way imagine when i get back
and i dye my hair back and i was like
what happened like i had coven
and but and people are gonna understand
okay yeah i had covet
yes like are you doing any more hair
colors
i don't know i might i i feel like i'm
i'm at i'm
it's getting a little bit like people
are trying to get worried about me
you can only do blue hair for like now
it's like it's like
i did ping for a month i did blue for
now it's time to get back to being an
adult but now you're you're
you're blue and purple maybe you just
even write it out because
the fact that you know that is a bigger
problem what you didn't know i was like
i was like i'm blue
i don't know what color my hair is at
this point which is a bigger issue so
yeah i think i need to get back to being
an adult and go back to brown
no yeah you could go full purple no it's
here's the problem is that number one uh
i really liked it at the beginning
because
when you dye your hair fully pink people
stop asking you
for advice and like help on anything
like no one asks for your
in way can you weigh in on this like
everyone's good on anything don't ask
her like if people don't ask you
people leave you alone they want you to
watch their kids they don't expect you
to like respond to emails
i'm very ticklish do you have ever deal
with people that are so ticklish that it
yeah and then i just scream and i'm like
don't move
or else it's gonna look like uh you know
that emoji that's like
and they're all like unsure and their
mouths like squiggly somebody's like
yeah that that's happened before but if
you see that you're fucking something up
do you just cover
or you just i try to go over it thicker
and just make it a little thicker
but sometimes you will twitch
involuntarily should this camera come in
i guess i'm gonna go here okay is my
foot so gross this is so much more
intimate than like getting naked for a
man like you
seeing my friends i'm so much more
embarrassed
you're about to get so many points on
wiki feet what are you
i know this better not ruin my wiki feed
score i feel like i have a five
wiki feed score mostly because aren't
that many photos
how tall are you five ten oh nice yeah
yeah you're you're i think we're the
same height you just
you haven't you haven't given up yet so
you wear heels
i think yeah i wear i wear yeah yeah no
you stick boots
with five c's i'm getting a tattoo yes
uh
from hannah and what is it to say is it
going to say emily and whitney forever
emily and whitney in a heart do you want
that
i mean no but it's funny or we could do
the smiley face
oh yeah yeah and then well why don't you
do smiley face on emily
i can't do it okay you're scared i'm
scared
so e plus w heart
but i want the smiley face let's do the
smiley face smiley face okay and how
long does it take to do those
i might i might go over it like twice
okay or three times
okay it takes longer to do the sketching
than the actual doing right
while we're waiting for that i would
just like to say
jen aniston uh wrote me back
uh hannah loves jen aniston and we sent
a video
she said she remembers me
yes
my name is my name wow
guys if you guys don't know she is
literally my
um my bad screen my phone screen
holy cow guys
what she lit she said she remembered me
yes how do you feel about the fact that
a lot of people feel about you the way
you feel about jazz does that make you
want to quite what you're doing
does this make you uncomfortable about
being famous
yes because a lot of people i feel bad
for jen you're a lot of people's jedison
so i just want you to know how
creepy your life is she just seems so
put together
god she's an actual icon i guess guys
she remembers me
we should do i love jan on one and then
the smiley face i will do that i will
literally
do that on my forehead all right here we
go
okay hold on back why is the
anticipation so much worse than actually
doing it
okay i've gotten tattoos before i'm an
adult i've just never gotten one on my
phone be careful because
am i even able to walk on my feet is
here uh yeah i walked i
actually before covid after i got the hi
how are you on the bottom of my foot i
went out and i partied
yeah but you have joy in your heart
you are a happy resilient person i'm
hanging by a thread oh no
you'll be good i also have really high
arches so that's perfect it's apparently
a problem it won't wear off
yeah it's a problem for me it's like a
problem like great for uh tattoos on the
back i'm supposed to wear insoles i had
bone spurs and
me too me too and then i was like
whatever i'd rather just be in pain and
fucking have to go to this appointment
[Music]
oh yeah that doesn't hurt barely did
anything yeah it doesn't really really
need
i turned out my entire body's numb
i thought my
who knew it's not just my
oh feels like um it's kind of like what
it feels like when you get an iud put in
it's like a creepy kind of like
nettlesome
pain
oh she's very focused you do take this
very seriously i'm yeah i'm trying
this is like really what you want to do
with your life imagine
it's sweet you're so successful at
something and she's like you're like
michael jordan playing baseball she's
like but i just want to be a tattoo
artist
it's leaking a little bit but it's okay
i'm just going to do a wipe down this
isn't what it actually looks like
ink okay thank you am i called leaking
that's called bleeding
um let me correct let me no okay we're
gonna give you the proper term
uh that's called bleeding that's called
a punctured artery in the foot
oh gosh i love that noise
it's such a sexy noise it's such a
soothing noise you're like oh
the sound of bad decisions oh
guys when you guys want to suck our feet
this is what we're doing by the way
we're like
like you like it and we have to like
that might not have stuck is that a
frowny face
did you do the squiggle emoji
no we might i might even wipe it off and
nothing stuck i have a very light hand i
was going to say i
it's it doesn't hurt at all what you're
doing but maybe that means really
i need to go indeed i feel it i feel i
need to go in deeper i do feel it i
think
i can't tell because i'm trying so hard
to trick myself into not feeling it i
don't know if i'm
succeeding or if it's just not deep
enough okay this is gonna be
sex all the time i think i felt that can
you just do it again deeper
i just i'm not sure oh yeah nothing
nothing well a little bit a little bit
we are getting there
dude it's going to be cute
oh this is so cute all you fetishes just
out there
i'm i'm doing this to send you a thumbs
up
a lot of women nice smiley faces women
who like men to fetishize their food
i'll take the compliment yeah i'll take
it i'm not going to reject a compliment
even if you're mentally ill when you're
making it
are you feeling that yeah that
definitely is deeper
[Music]
okay yeah this is really a
sensation that is unfamiliar to me okay
you know what it is it's just an
unfamiliar kind of pain on the foot
it's like it's like tickle pain you know
you know what people are tickling you
and you don't want them to tickle you
you know and you're six and they're not
related to you
um no that's not so i just mean like you
know when someone's tickling you
oh my gosh that's just like you can
never but you know my god it's tickling
you and it like
hurts but you're laughing so they don't
know to stop oh my god oh my goodness
okay i think that's it yeah i think we
got it you've had enough of smelling my
foot
she's like i've had enough i just
stopped i'm like
i know i did not think to like wash my
feet i thought
i was gonna do it back like on my
shoulder
what just put it against did i fuck up
oh fuck
and that's your tattoo did i i mean look
it is very
artsy it is very it's like a moroe
painting or like a jackson pollock
it's a visit you did i just fuck it up
or no it doesn't
i just got it all over the table i do
need to go over it again
we have to do something for jen we have
to do a gen if you're not if you're not
doing the bottom of your foot i'll do
the bottom of my other foot
why don't we do i need to go unless you
like it like this
i think we should go over it again okay
okay you're the boss you're the expert i
can't see it
wait wait can i um yeah i can't even see
it i trust you for
some reason i know before by the way
i know it's weird i really like her and
we're like old new friends
you're a stranger to me i mean i don't
really know you
you know what i mean yeah i know
wild wild and i'm marking you for life
for life
it'll fade doesn't it fade on the bottom
i love it you're like it's fine
when you guys have your epic public
falling out it'll fade
don't worry get it covered don't worry
ah
okay i think i think and i know i say
that every time but i think
that's no good you never know art is
never done only abandoned
who said that leonardo da vinci i think
michelangelo sorry
but you didn't know either so okay here
we go
what's that water looks good ladies and
gentlemen don't happy foot
we don't see gender here happy feet yeah
i mean my feet are so disgusting maybe
this is like helping with a healing like
me embracing my
ugly feet that's so cute it's so cute
kiss it
i'm kidding put it in your mouth wait
what do you see i don't know
do it with it okay do you like it yes
sorry i do want to look at it i'm
realizing do you want me to
go over it i think i should really yeah
there's one part that
cute so cute she's like you know what
i don't know here's what i'll say the
way someone drives it drives uh uh
uh uh for women we can't drive um uh
the way that a smiley face the way that
the eyes are separated makes him like
look so
like happy when i draw a smiley face
they look evil and
lost and dangerous they're just i know
it's like eyebrows
yeah when i draw a smiley face they look
like their eyebrows are furrowed like
even the way you shoot or even just the
eyes like like your circles are
your little like like it's just like a
happy happy face my happy face
my happy faces look like they're faking
it my happy faces look like it's
just two more times okay there's just
two more
sections having so the one on top of
your foot did that hurt like
all fuck oh yeah oh and plus that was a
cover-up of another tattoo
but i think because it was a cover-up it
they like damaged the nerves on the
first time so it didn't really hurt that
much
this is just army hammer's face i
had to remove that tattoo ah
oh a good goo bob
oh
so basically the more you're going over
it the more it's already
wounded skin as you go
on you got it so you're basically
jamming a needle into an open wound got
it i got it
i got it oh yeah there we go
is it good yeah cute good look at that i
mean
we've adorned the ugliest part of my
body i'm so does this
mean i'm a partner in the brand yeah
merch like so this is so i just get like
20 percent
20 yeah company i'm not like i'm not
doing this for fun
yes just sleeping in court how would i
not have been a partner
how would i not have been a partner in
her merch company
why would i have gotten a tattoo of it
oh extreme tattoo merch would be
cool she told me verbally fifty percent
of the company
yeah um okay let's do it on this side
let's do i love jen
jennifer aniston yeah i want that on me
well bitch you haven't done it and i'm
we're on my podcast now i think you'll
get what we'll get this matching tattoo
this might take a while though like it
might this like
to do all that it might take like 30
minutes how about just i heart
j i heart j okay i'm fully getting an i
love jennifer aniston tattoo
and that's the best tattoo ever
i'm probably gonna go home and tattoo it
on myself
can you do your own foot yeah you're
right i did my own foot
i tattooed that's crazy on my toes
it's all black and blue right now but
it's okay that ugh
what a nightmare i just feel like yeah
the toes would probably be super
like it's like you know when i derma
roll on the face which is the thing with
the tiny needles
to put the make sure that all your
product is absorbing your face over the
lip
is the worst like it's just so random
where we have nerve endings
oh does this one hurt more because it's
more like dead skin
tattoo artists are so bomb because
and hot because you're you're most
nervous and you want to talk and make
small talk and they won't
do anything oh no you can't it's due
it's hot dude i was
i was tattooing uh this girl's neck last
night and
i wasn't breathing and after i would
stop a stroke i would be like
oh because you like didn't want to
breathe down her neck or something i
know i just i feel like i'm more
you're dead i'm more like i have a
steadier hand it's almost like
uh if you're playing call of duty and
you're like doing like a sniper shot
and then the the character is like after
you you hit it
because they like hold the breath do you
guys we haven't even talked to you guys
play
you want to play tonight i'll see you in
the goo leg
what does any of this mean dave do you
play what is what is she saying is she
harassing you
uh no what does that mean what's the gu
lag it's uh
where you go when you die and i just
call it call of duty
i'm not good at a war zone at all so i'm
just like but i do win a lot in gulag
are you just doing this to just show
people how shitty a girlfriend i am
compared to you is this what this whole
podcast
i am doing this because i'm alone and i
need friends so
these are like virtual friends i can
just talk to it's like
so you've never met any of the people
you game with in person oh no i i game i
game with a lot of my guy friends yeah
okay yeah what's your and this is on
twitch uh it it could be on twitch if
you want to stream it okay however you
could just play and not even stream it
just for fun until 5am every night
you're very patient about
uh explaining this to me without having
judgment in your voice
exhaustion what happened to that
what what what do you ever want to game
live like in
stadiums oh when i had energy i
i just have dollar signs in my eyes i'm
like would you like to tour yeah
like i'm literally just well i just
created this game room in my house and
normal well normal gamers game rooms are
like just very futuristic
you shouldn't you should you should
design arcades
i should because my game or my game room
is literally like
the hannah stocking experience the
promised rainforest cafes
they're really really fun but the water
fucking stinks oh like the what they
ever noticed that you got a rainforest
cafe
yeah i did actually and it's like tap
when the water comes on you're like
oh yeah is that sewage water like what's
the like
yes like everyone's kind of you can tell
the waiters are bummed when the water
goes off there's like
the mess yeah the waiters are just like
slipping on the floor they're like enjoy
your fucking potatoes
like it is like and then every now and
then when when the
lightning would go off and the gorillas
are like oh
god the waitress is there like
oh fuck god hit in the face with a
toucan again
oh what a fun welcome to rainforest cafe
it's not making me laugh just like is it
a teardrop or is it like a sewage
droplet from the rain
this is so dumb
and i'm so into it dude for me this is
when else
are we gonna be able to do dumb like
shit that's like right i think the
pandemic let's take something good away
from it which is like
that thing you've been putting off or
that thing you're like i can't do that
just fucking that's where my hair is
purple and i'm getting foot tattoos
that's why i started tattooing it's like
who cares
your fullest thing it's it's the
uh live like you're gonna die tomorrow
because you fucking might like what have
you been not doing because you're like
i'll do that later in my life i'll do
that in my head
just just do it now for the fuck of you
like do it this weekend mm-hmm because
you don't know how long yeah it's
amazing you can always stop you can't
you know
you can always dye your hair back brown
people say like oh your hair's blue now
i'm like
yeah no yeah you know yeah no no it
doesn't stay permanent you know how hair
works it's gonna grow out but tattoos
shit that's really good you guys have a
tattoo without permanent as a tattoo
guys i don't know the basic concept of a
tattoo
does that hurt nope it's a tiny pain
okay cool it's a little baby pain it's
like a little toddler
just like stabbing you with their baby's
knife
you can't be mad it's like a cute pain
yeah hold on move your foot like that
oh wow okay
just a lot of confidence i am not tired
hold on yeah why don't you here we go
okay yeah you're i'm fully making you
like
engage your core to do this
jen's going to see this
by the way she still wants to get this
right it's so sweet when in doubt do it
for jen
who are your favorite tattoo artists um
there's this
guy named um uh jack
townsend who's really good and also this
other guy
uh n dot a dot l he's really really far
uh-huh yeah if you're you have to be
good to have that annoying of a name
you must be good for people to say dot
dot
like that you have to be an instagram
name i'm not really sure what you know
he's the best tattoo artist he must be
because yeah
you can't have that name and not be and
be like mediocre
yeah um all right the j did not stick at
all
so here we go we will go again j round
two
you could also do courtney or lisa look
at that let's see
let's see so how how did you and
jennifer aniston meet
i'm just she reached out and was like
i'm dying to be friends with you
you can't are you serious no i
i i found i gotta i went and i bought a
star maps
uh drove to her house and um
they sound like me something i would do
yeah
and they just you know it's usually
through one of her security guards that
i get a message
the way they relay it like she's so good
she's just so busy
she's very busy she's busy and usually
just the lapd will deliver a message
from her to me to my home
it's titled restraining order yeah yeah
yeah yeah she's like me
she's like meet me downtown next week
and i'm like cool at this courthouse
cool
she loves to hang out at the courthouse
you feel this
yeah hell yeah i'm trying to like talk
and like nervously distract myself but
that one's not bad that's not bad that's
like a good pain
okay that hurts so good do not call me
army
always so she's always so shocked i
am there's going to be a point she's so
shocked when i like uh
say crazy shit there will come a time in
your life too where you stop giving a
fuck
yeah like and it's not now it is
you're not a very absolute i feel like
again whenever you're saying uh
you still have a lot to build don't
throw it all away yet
by saying the dumb shit i say that's not
worth it
i know don't burn bridges the way i and
when you say that stuff i'm just like
i just like to i'm i'm literally got a
backpack full of grenades and
i'm just like i have been so beaten down
by this business that i'm just like
i'm just throwing grenades left and
right i love it
as you should though i just don't even
give a shit anymore um
uh oh are you no is this not the big
reveal
no and i don't even have a backup career
i don't know what the fuck i'm thinking
you have like nine backup careers
this will need a few more times to go
over okay
we have a really good base layer though
yeah but that's like thicker skin on top
it is very thick thick with five shoes
but i think this is like
it's you know it's like shadowy it has a
really really cute shadow
undertone and it kind of reminds me of
your white tattoos
the ones that no one can see well do you
want to reveal what you tattooed on me
will you just break my foot so i can i
can't i want to
i can't because i still need to take a
lot of the income what does it look like
what does it say is it like a dick uh
not a dick a spaceship
a spaceship with two engines yeah two
engines on either side
okay so oh no no bad it's good
it will be good here's why am i going to
get sued you get worse before you get
better
and that's this this is going to be
worse before you better the only thing i
don't want to hear from my tattoo artist
i want to hear from like anyone else
anyone but okay wait i'll take a picture
also not all the ink is off i mean
it looks it looks like like
um it looks like i just lightly put
pencil
over it looks like um
um it looks like
it looks like do you remember in true
detective when the serial killer carved
into the tree
[Laughter]
it's kind of like that uh only on my
body forever
uh no i i genuinely think this will go
away in like two days no i love it i'm
dude
it's the bottom of my foot yeah i think
it has a lot of personality it's good
and then i've got this little guy oh
yeah this one's
this one's a keeper so dumb they're so
funny
yeah i normally like never let anyone
see my feet but now i'm going to start
to just be
proud and i yeah i had really bad
athletes foot in
high school when i played basketball and
it was like so embarrassing that i think
i have like trauma around my feet being
out
but not anymore lucky your lucky day
hello oh it looks amazing it's so
cute i love it all right and while
you're disassembling i want to ask you a
question
yeah about like your
future like looking for like do you want
to be
in movies and television or you're just
like that's a waste of time i'm building
a business i love that
i i love that that realm you want to be
less famous
i want to go to hollywood just to have
less people see what i do here's the
thing i do
think that there is a stigma uh between
um traditional media
there's internet media and i know this
but it's not that real
it's we're jealous and we're jealous and
we're mad
but uh i kind of like i just want to
mesh the two
i know like a few of my internet friends
are doing a great job doing that but i
would love to be
in traditional media don't really care
what it pays yeah but i just want to be
you know that internet person that helps
blend
that's fascinating yeah you should do a
you already could have done a movie i
mean like but jackass like that was
really like they were kind of just like
they
just scrambled it all together yeah you
know what i'm saying you probably
already have enough footage to put a
movie together
yeah just compile it all yeah like a
document like a big like compilation
video
i am and i am going to be in a movie
though it's coming out yeah one movie uh
it's called um vanquisher cool by
directed by george gallo why are you so
you're like i could you have a little
bit of like
freeman's in it you have like shyness
around it i know i just
i can't i can't believe it that's just
you go in an audition or do they just
give it to you
they uh um they are really good friends
with my mom
but let me ask you do you by the way um
would you
uh do you ever feel like when you get
hired for something
they call you in and you're like oh they
want me to post like
something john's saying i wouldn't say
for that movie specifically but
yes i have been hired on like other
things
where yeah they're like so like the
social media
not not this project that i'm talking
about but like previous ones that i
won't name
yeah yeah i have been like okay well
here's our socials this is our at
our hashtag i'm just like yeah yeah
because
i know like you're here today
obviously so that i'll post about you i
know you're using me for my following
it's fine i'm fine with it you're a
hustler
collective it's friendship
you get more out of this than i do and
that's fine i'm fine i'm a giver i want
to support the next generation of women
in comedy
whatever i can do to help you boost your
numbers
hey yes and my future uh
comedy stand-up show because there's
also this weird thing that i think is
important to
say that out loud like because
it doesn't occur this i i'm gonna go on
a rant
everyone just settle in uh get cozy uh
grab a drink
all right um uh i was on a
set yesterday because of the covet i
don't know if i know i mentioned this
but i was on a set yesterday
did everyone get that and they brought
up three times four times
um no but it was it was with covid like
normally there's like
people going like with the wardrobe and
then and there's all these like union
rules where you let people do their
thing in the clothes and
you know and they get your mic but with
kovid
it was very much like you do everything
yourself and just you know it was like
but the rules are also very amorphous
and vegan you didn't really
know or whatever but i found myself the
first time in a really long time
remembering advice that i got
from my dad that um blew my mind which
in relationships i was always the one
that loved too much
i was always the one that did everything
i was always the one that gave too much
i was always
and um he said something to me once he
was like be careful how self-sufficient
you come off
because it never occurs to anyone to
help you never encourage anyone that you
need help
right so if you're not going to ask for
help because i had a hard time asking
for help or being able to acknowledge
any kind of weakness
and then uh trying to become so
self-sufficient so everyone thinks i'm a
strong woman and not needy and weak or
fragile
and i was on set and i was like i'm so
thirsty and i'm sorry
but how would anyone know that and i'm
in a mask and people can't read my face
and whatever
yeah but in terms of like like you
and like hollywood there are a lot of
assumptions
like your name comes up and stuff and
people like ah she's fucking so rich why
would she ever want to do this or like
or whatever or she's so she's got her
own thing going why did you want do you
mean like there is
someone that needs to connect the
world's going
we want to be in business with you you
want to be in business with us let's
figure out the way that works
where we're both blending the two words
right now they're like circling each
other
with a a resentment of like uh
but but but then there's some amazing
like
huge movie stars like kevin hart and the
rock and
they have massive social media followers
yeah they take it very seriously yeah
yeah
so there's that aspect and then there's
like oh yeah oh you
you just do i can't post anything about
that
that would look bad yeah but yeah yeah
that's really what happens is
you you're already in a situation where
you have a bunch of people like
making sure your business right you're
then you're just if you get in business
with big corporations they're just gonna
go like and
you can't have coke in this photo yeah
it just becomes it becomes about that
shit but that's just business that's
just business
i know but yeah i i mean i think it's
it's a lot better than what it was about
like four or five years ago
it was absolutely you cannot be in this
movie because of that and then it
started becoming like
oh i would love for this girl to be in
this movie because yeah she could pose
about it or
or benefit it and then i won't spend as
much money on
advertising for this movie because i
have her that's stupid
it is but at least it's kind of starting
to mesh
they should pay you for posting uh yeah
that is
that is a not this podcast but other
productions should pay you
no but it's like no that's a different
service so it's like it's like
this is why hollywood needs to fucking
catch up fast because they're going
okay um no one's watching anything so
let's just put you
in this cause you'll post about it later
it's like no bitch write the part
for her make it jersey just let's write
the movie for her
yeah and then it's organic and natural
it's it's
that doesn't work they tried to do it i
saw it happen where influencers would
come on and do tv shows
for sweeps week it did not bump the
numbers it doesn't matter because your
fans
they get your internet yeah yes it's
like that would be new fans they would
follow you but
not the metrics are showing they don't
follow right away they're watching you
on set like i'm on the set of this
marvel movie and da
da da da i mean maybe that's different
tomorrow maybe it'll like come out or
whatever
and your fans if they're younger they
have to get their mom to help but it's
like
yes for the most part they're like oh my
god hannah's on whatever this weekend
i'll watch it this weekend
like i'll get to it eventually because
they've got you right here in their hand
mm-hmm
yeah so it's just it's just like it's
such a different that just really pisses
me off because it's like
i feel like so many content creators
hollywood didn't either or get or they
didn't do the system or they didn't go
through it and they're like i'm just
gonna fucking do this on my own
yeah or they didn't give them a chance
because i still feel like
movie acting is different than internet
acting yeah
obviously so then if people see you know
like
somebody acting crazy or doing like a
weird persona because it connects with
the kids
yeah they're seeing that as oh this girl
can't do a dramatic role
but it's like you know they do that they
do that no matter what if you want a
sitcom they'd say it if you were in a
drama they'd say you can't do comedy
everyone needs to say something about
you that's not true so
they feel better today because they're
you know what i mean it's like it never
ends
yeah but everybody needs to know
internet acting is different
than it's also real acting and yeah
sitcom versus serious roles
but it's also like a lot of people that
are watching like it's like it's almost
like um
there's some videos that are like almost
reminiscent to me because a lot of
people are watching with the sound off
and
they're on going from here to here it's
like a two minute bite a five minute
bite whatever
um and uh it's almost like some of them
feel like
like like charlie chaplin or something
the physical humans tell us
to be able to communicate with just is
so refreshing especially because i feel
like comedy is going in this direction
with
a lot of shit that's how that's how i
feel like that's how it gets yeah sorry
i feel like that's how um like
especially like internet videos get
global leave viral they transcend
because it's language barrier and uh
yeah
exactly like language but it's also like
i think that's so important to say that
because like whenever like snobby
comedians are like oh this is like
and you're like but that they that's
what you're supposed to that's for that
do you know what i'm saying yeah that's
it's like it has to be super visual
medium you have to communicate a ton
with your face
really really quickly in body language
and then
go into like certain characters if
you're talking about your mom like do
your little thing or whatever
yeah i think siblings yeah i have a i
have older sister
yeah let's get along very different
she's a doctor and she lives in
washington
what kind of doctor uh she uh she helps
people give birth
wow that's why i know
that's wild yep
has everything together she cleans i
don't
um yeah she has chickens i'm like
staring at you i'm kind of obsessed with
you you just like there's not a lot of
darkness that happens with you
like you know what we went over this i
suppress i suppress
and suppress as soon as we called
countries
but only my lawyers no but you but do
you like i
i very much i've struggled my whole life
with uh silence and
and like like when there's a silent
moment especially in front of cameron's
enough you can usually
see someone unravel and you're just like
oh really oh that's such a nice
compliment thank you it's like it's
really whatever
like between the therapy and your
parents i don't know who owes the
compliment but i'm just so
impressed so you see people unravel in
moments of silence no it's just like you
know that when like when there's a
silent moment
you're just claiming your space and
you're going it's your job to ask me
another question
do you know what i'm saying that is so
funny where's comedians
i need to learn that skill maybe it's
the the virus load
see if you're just trying to not get
my job it's like i'm just like no but
there's something interesting about like
like
that that has just taken me so long of
like any time you're like
even on a date or on a freaking job
interview whatever it is like when you
just
it's quiet so you just start kind of
running your mouth oh yeah
i used i used to do that um but i got
over it
when you're done talking you just stop
talking
but i'm saying that's a skill like i
don't like that's just a good skill
also it's a skill in your sense that you
can just think of topics off the top of
your head and just
and keep going with it yeah and run with
it yeah
yeah no i i'd rather do yours yours
looks more fun
yours looks more like a fun life choice
um okay last thing i'm going to ask you
because we do this on the podcast with
everyone is um red flags in the podcast
i always want someone to walk away with
like a new like
i don't know insider piece of advice or
just something or
um i'm gonna ask you the best advice
you've gotten and then any red flags in
relationships
the best advice that i've gotten i would
say recently
i saw something online it wasn't like
somebody told it to me
it was don't worry about if they like
you worry about if you like them
right write that down everybody oh but i
don't like anyone
oh no no no if that's the case and i
never see anybody
but it kind of it kind of goes back to
what we're talking about like
oh i hope i didn't hurt their feelings
or whatever like you know
just worry about yourself your feelings
and take care of yourself it's taken me
i mean that is like i mean that's like
that's like a gnarly concept that i like
wish i had heard earlier in my life
because i was like i just heard that
last week too and i just been
replaying in my head on repeat like you
know when you hear like a great piece of
advice and you're like where were you
fucking
15 years ago
exactly my whole life and like if
someone wants to be friends with me like
well you get to be friends with me yeah
if someone wants to date me it's like
what am i going to say no
i guess we're just together now okay i'm
going to wait until you cheat on me or
something like i just have to become
such an asshole that you break up with
me
like uh like i had such a reactive
take on uh people's approval that's so
interesting
and then yeah we run around and then
it's also i'm like
uh if something's negative online you go
to your profile and you're like
i'm looking at your profile you're
fucking loser you've
contributed nothing to society i still
i'm still upset that you don't like me i
know
you don't even know you proceed
i know um regarding red flags so i think
i i just have too many
uh probably like little ones that's good
that's there's no such thing as too many
uh too much self-respect i have too many
red flags there's
so many i mean i could i could go up i
could go on and on and on
but obviously a clear red flag is if
you're
hanging out you know with a guy for the
first time and
can't get off his phone he's hiding the
phone no no no that's yeah that's
no no car if you know like he just asks
you to move in off the top
he doesn't have credit cards that's just
you that's not other
other women are like it's never happened
before um
yeah i don't know um
[Music]
steals from you this is getting very
autobiographical
and um do you need to borrow some money
are you okay do you need some
should we hey so i know um
yes it's real specific um
um
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that was lemaire but whatever um
[Laughter]
those are good those are good those are
like that was great your
your red flag but yeah they're i like
the smaller
non-obvious ones the little ones the
little ones
little like that those are the like
little ones like um
oh if he i i think if he acts like
completely different around his friends
than he does with you personally
i've never met any of my boyfriend's
friends hmm
that might be a red flag too wait you've
met
wait but guys you date larry you meet
what his friends
oh huh by the way i just got stuck on
this thing with my necklace
um yeah what do you mean oh to fuck them
in front of him oh yeah okay
oh um
i don't know why that like raised
something in my head no i
um i also think if they speed in parking
garages
red flag that is maybe
the best one i've heard really 100
yeah like they don't care about
themselves they don't care about their
car their personal belongings they don't
care about
people walking to their car that is such
a good one also
unnecessarily backing into the space so
you can
save time pulling out yeah you're not
like you're like the the amount of time
you're
like guys have to pull in back into the
hardest possible space or something yeah
i don't know what they're like
yeah why are there so many tire streaks
what screech is going on in the freaking
parking garages
why didn't but why don't you just pull
in and back out
like a lot of red flags happen in
parking garages
a lot yeah how long it takes you to get
out of your car if you know somebody's
waiting to take your parking if you ever
date a man and hear the tire screech
in a parking garage if he's not
logan paul if he doesn't you know what
i'm saying he's not doing it for as a
career he's not a race car driver if
he's not a lewis hamilton
yeah i don't know what that is um but um
that's such a good one yeah oh fuck
that's a good one
um what else drive recently uh i had a
weird little one
guys that delete texts as they go
oh and dms i don't know i don't even
know you can do that
i always delete my dm's in texts just to
happen
how did you develop that habit and why
what are you hiding
yeah red flag that's a great one too wow
but what is it with you
with with why do you guys have to dm on
instagram why can't you just text
like what is this snapchat i'm saying
why is everybody's snapchat
i thought that was gone i thought
snapchat disappeared not just the
messages i thought the entire app
disappeared so that's on you
and you need to get new friends but uh
no but i don't um
you know that all that's like going to
like facebook owns everything we text on
instagram
yeah exactly yeah bad
yeah imessage whatsapp facetime
not call me why is it dms yeah
interesting following porn stars or
lingerie models
yeah i'm good liking all their pictures
just google
porn and watch it when you want to alone
yeah why are you making me know why are
you making the public
also why do you know like look at a
naked girl during the day like
just as you're looking at you don't know
what that's going to be sandwiched in
between on your feet
yeah yeah i mean your niece is like porn
star boyfriend
oh you know i don't know how your grids
i don't know exactly i don't know what
else you follow
i know i know and then it pops up on
your for you page or not for you page
the explore page and then you're like oh
why why is this here oh
i see the guy i'm talking to like okay
wait wait are you telling me
that your explore page gives you insight
on the guy you're dating yeah who
they follow because yeah
you've been dea sometimes sometimes it
pops up once in a blue moon yeah
you can find out that's the tea i know
that's the
full right there not only is that the
tea i need to like
i need to like make some calls like it's
like it
may be like i need to put on my
instagram right now that's the type of
information that is like
changes your life in a way that might
not be
good oh yeah i know i know
that that's a dice like i haven't even
put that together
because i like my explore page is all
like girls twerking and i'm always like
i guess it's because i follow cardi b
and i don't know yeah he's probably
important but he follows
a look at his follows this could be
because it's like the top five people
that you text with the most
because also if you if i if you
text me my birthday's coming up
which it came and it's raining out
i'll get ads for an umbrella oh
on the thing yeah so i had this whole
conversation with someone uh uh at the
internet
um i talked to the internet guy you say
that i talked to the president of the
internet and um he told me
uh that it's the top five people that
you dm with and then if they say it's my
birthday or it's whatever
and then they'll market you things that
that person has clicked on or googled on
their computer
on their wi-fi which is a separate
cord which just makes it especially
impressive
very impressive robots technology are we
in a simulation or
not this is out of out of control but
very smart i love you i end this very
awkwardly
um what do you want to talk about
because let's be honest you need
promotion
for your thing you're struggling
in your career oh my goodness i love you
more whitney
thank you so much for having me on the
podcast i always have so much fun
hanging out
i'm always curious um i think i've just
i do not recommend it
it's just like it's just like hard it's
hard it's it's it's hard for my
personality type because i'm
just like beat myself up too much but
what um
i'm just curious if that's something
that that i think it's something that
might maybe happen will happen down the
road
because you are uh yeah i'm just curious
because for someone like you
it's really a matter of not what you're
gonna do it's when you're gonna do it
and like in what order
yeah i think that's definitely down the
road and then there's this pressure to
do like everything right the second i
know
you're a woman and you're managing
everything else that i've just
got on board with and then you can do a
podcast any time
that's what i'm saying do that when
you're like like done like yeah when
you're ready to look like this every day
and when you're ready to just let let
people think
that you've had a manic break and you
don't care
because i'm still getting over here um
who cares if i like you
not if they like you oh see of course i
turned it into
um uh so okay so there's this the last
thing i'll say is there's a george haas
does this um
attachment style class that helps you
change your attachment
strategy you i see the link no i think
you're secure
no no i think your
intimacy issues abandonment yeah that's
the opposite
abandonment issues are a form of
intimacy issues don't let me blow your
mind but i will
your brain just yeah your face just
first my eyes starts bleeding
just make the camera side eye i just i
know it's like the tear but
can you just cheat the camera like she's
something horrible happens someone like
can you cheat the camera
i'm just like just cheat out just banana
out banana banana
just rag zoom focus real quick um i
forgot what was it
something i love you keep going okay so
i love you okay so george haas
the whole thing is like codependence we
get entrenched in relationships
and we don't uh uh even if it's toxic
and
and it's addictive it's hard to leave
right um and
uh the uh like the familiar pain is
better than the unfamiliar unknowing
pain but the whole thing blah
and uh there's a meditation
uh for preoccupied attachment styles
which is like anxious when you're like
worried the person's abandoning you or
leave or you know you only text me once
today or
she didn't call me back at this time you
know that what are they doing
that old stuff yeah that comes up um
and uh uh the inner child reactions and
the the meditation
is i love you keep going like
i love you like keep going so so what do
you do you meditate and then you say
that in your head you kind of just say
in your head i love you keep going and
it's
there's a little bracelet like it's just
a a a
it sounds kind of like like whatever but
it's
it's actually really powerful and
rewiring your brain that's not like i
love you you need to
be at my disposal all the time because
relationships can't grow if you're
suffocating each other
so it's like you go out with your
friends go have experiences i'm gonna
separation is healthy yeah
come back in and now i have something to
talk to you about because we're not
together twenty four fucking times and
it keeps it alive
and i love you keep going keep growing
like because if i don't want you
in five years to go like i'm the same
person i was five years ago because of
this like you have to keep growing and
relationships yeah and um but i am like
so codependent fucked up we were all
going to go get tattoos and we didn't by
the way
um and uh we were like going down to the
tattoo thing and i
had heard the meditation that day and um
we went down i was like oh so what is it
i love you don't leave me
and they were like no i'm like no keep
going
that's not that's so good by the way the
white eagles it's amazing
but i love that the idea that i thought
that was the saying
i know you're like i need a check-in
it's the opposite
i have you don't need me like i'm just
like but yeah but it's um
uh i'm very excited i have a new tattoo
two new tattoos who knew and we will
we'll we'll go over that no we'll have
another session yeah
we'll go down to the doctor's face
we'll go to her house actually mark
mahoney yeah hey jen can you
pay to have this removed this is
technically your
fault i'm i'm gonna be there too just to
make sure i think
she's gonna pay for the dr tatoff
session yes
to fix the the tetanus in my body oh my
goodness
uh i love you so much what a dream um
don't write elephants uh that's what i
say at the end of every podcast
uh don't ride elephants um mostly uh
african elephants can't be tamed hannah
i love you
thank you for doing this even though it
probably hurt your career quite frankly
um oh my gosh i love you so much like
you haven't done a ton of podcasts
no this is my third one that's so wild
simon rex
impulsive and now this yeah that's right
i haven't listened to you on logan
paul's show really yeah
i also tattooed somebody on there what
yeah
i thought you saw that i thought you
know i did it no i don't watch
impulsive sorry that's not my go-to
program at night
logan oh my gosh i actually love you i
think i'm going on it
oh yeah i was supposed to really yeah i
was supposed to go on with him
mike all such great great guys yeah i
don't know them but i i don't do
well with like hot um successful men i
get mad at them
i'm sorry oh yeah and logan's like i
just dropped three mail on some pokemon
cards i'm like i get that i'm like but
how
like i get very like adversarial with
men like rich hot young men i'm just
like but what if you fucking donated i
get like
i think yo my my abs are sore from
rapping so much you are so funny i
appreciate you so much for having me
here i love you we're gonna make you
come back
and i'm sorry i better come back i love
you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you